as a chance going for the double tap
it's every kid dreams of playing on the
world stage they're deep deep into offer
the feeling of becoming the best at the
thing they love squishy with the
challenge torment again gimmick with a
shooting opportunity good first touch
that shot if you ever get to fulfill
that dream place it down screwsie's
there sit back
even fewer get to do it in a way that
they never expected
moving the player to invent the
Johnny in a turnaround and go for this
he does get it
nice pass off the back well that's fishy
[Music]
[Applause]
growing up in Toronto Canada Mariano's
squishy muffins arruda spent his days
fantasizing about crosses
[Applause]
and Kevin Elson thought about it's gonna
put it in good curve on the ball the
thing is unlike most esports prodigies
his childhood dream wasn't to play video
games for a living
squishy had another stage in mind don't
pro in in football soccer is something
that I always wanted to do but like it
always seemed little far-fetched cuz
there's so many kids like growing up you
see some of the kids wanting to go pro
in that right and like it just seems
impossible that's not to say squishy
didn't love video games or that they
weren't a close second to his obsession
with soccer growing up as a kid I played
a lot of soccer or football whatever you
want to whatever you want to call it and
it was just probably like my favorite
pastime like I'd go outside but my
father every now and then just pass the
ball around to learn new skills new
tricks and stuff like that and yet in
spite of his deep inextinguishable love
for the game it had become clear by the
time squishy reached adolescence that
his career as a professional footballer
wasn't meant to be the only problem was
I am I'm pretty pretty bad as know when
it comes to running for long periods of
time so I couldn't actually like play it
all the time if I wanted to like I want
to say I get it I could have played all
the time because running up and down the
field for me I still like coughing up
blood and stuff and just like it
wouldn't be good from then on
squishy became increasingly serious
about video games and eventually eSports
it started off with GameCube I'm just
playing stuff like Mario Party and my
brother yeah just fun games like that
and then I got into competitive
uncharted 3 which is like a gun game and
that's what really got me to like new
tournaments and stuff and then in the
summer of 2015
something beautiful happened a 15 year
old squishy got his hands on a new game
one that managed to combine his two
greatest passions
[Applause]
squishy didn't just like rocket League
he felt as if it was made for him soccer
definite plays were open to like rock
they stole having a ball having cars
just like an exciting way to play soccer
that's pretty much what it was it's how
I saw it
that's why I got into it we did a month
of the game's release
squishy was uploading rocket league
content to his previously barren YouTube
channel
he'd always had a knack for handling
vectors mastering aerial movement and
well you know skillfully knocking things
into other things but it wasn't until he
started documenting his rocket League
rhyme that it became clear he had a mind
for soccer
[Music]
[Music]
but squishy was still leagues away from
being a pro player as far as anyone knew
he was just an insanely talented guy who
was filling a much needed hole in
YouTube's rocket League content what is
up guys squish him up to you and today
we got for you
episode number five of the road to grand
champ series the problem was that since
rocket league was still relatively new
there was basically no one in the
inaugural season of the our LCS who
hadn't spent time with the game's
predecessor supersonic acrobatic rocket
powered battle cars yeah you heard that
one right
I started playing supersonic acrobatic
rocket powered battle cars when I was in
sixth grade I visit my best friend the
first time and he played that game
supersonic everybody was appalled by the
curse and I played it there the first
time so that's how I got into it
destroyed playing sorry nothing a
physics-based football game that's
actually made well but squishy continued
to rank up invent jaw-dropping maneuvers
and rack up wins against some of the
best players in the world by late 2016
squishy had amassed over 40,000
subscribers racked up countless minor
tournament victories and was starting to
catch the attention of some truly
esteemed pros so I started in the the 1b
one scene like I just tried it well we
wants pretty much because I didn't have
to but it plays back then I was ps4
player and there was like a couple of my
good friends I put it all the time but
they started to slowly move over to PC
and I was like one of the last left on
ps4 right so I didn't have anybody close
anymore
so if layers like Justin was on energy
he was my friend from back refused for
it and he ended up switching to PC gain
a pursuit on G to do now he's my friend
back if he is for ended up switching the
PC so I had these players to play with
anymore so I was kind of just grinding
won't be one of my own one of those pros
was Kyle torment story hey what's up
guys so today we're back with another to
beat erode to make one and today we are
joined by torment one of my favorite
players to play with who'd been
competing in the our LCS since season 2
torment was respected well established
and exactly who squishy needed to help
him go from pub star to our LCS ready
in November of 2016 he and torment
grouped up with season 1 world's winner
Lachie neo and a
substitute named gimmick to form
squishies first real roster iris yes M
hit up Latino and they said that if
pre-made Arceus me torment and latch
that we could get signed wasn't it I it
was like obviously work champions so
that's why I was mad because of watch
but uh that's how pretty much we sold
for me we used TSN to still permit
that's how I got him that's pretty much
how I got him to join me because he had
his own team but he also like realized
that I had potential obviously extent
play with in the past and last was the
previous world champion so it wasn't a
bad pick for me it wasn't a bad choice
for him as soon as they set tire to
pitch
iris excelled come the new year they
were beating some of the previous
season's best teams and by March were
gearing up for the season three
qualifier
this was squishies first shot at the our
LCS and well it didn't go very well
we're all kind of off weren't playing
that great and this showed but squishy
was far from deterred within two months
he torment and their substitute gimmick
had left iris and the championship
winning teammate Lachie neo to form a
roster that was younger more dynamic and
more squishy centric they called
themselves the muffin men last got took
a step back from rock like he wasn't
enjoy going at the time he was playing
h1 a lot so he was relaxing like he
didn't really want to think about don't
stress about the game anymore for a
little bit and I think me and torment
decided we should get the gimmick a try
and try them out and we played amazingly
after finishing fourth in the inaugural
our LCS summer series the muffin men
managed to qualify for Dreamhack Atlanta
2017
which was then being touted as the most
stacked tournament in rocket league
history in addition to being squishies
first LAN it was the first time his
adoring YouTube followers were given the
opportunity to see his
face going into Atlanta there was still
something of a question mark surrounding
this young explosive band of car ballers
once it was over let me tell you
you knew the muffin man who would have
believed it that the muffin man could
have come out so strong against this
veteran roster eight second remaining
will in our team be eliminated I don't -
can they do it a Miss touch it's right
at fire Bernie has to defend the net
they slam it down the muffin man take
down that old American favors what a
displace was she in torment going
absolutely off after toppling NRG
esports in the quarterfinals and g2
esports in the semies i cannot even
imagine
I can't give it with an open net Kim ik
is gonna be the one to place it in for
the muffin and they move on to Grand
Finals The Bookman taped it out stay
tuned
fortitude squishy torment and gimmick
were tasked with taking down
gale-force in a grand final for the ages
gale-force esports trying to get their
second title of this summer after
winning a brisk and as you think into it
here again at dreamhack but either way
can have a fantastic champion the North
American David versus the EU Goliath
this is the clash of the two regions we
love it when the finals come out this
way I mean you say it's the the NA David
but look at the teams they've already
taken out they've already taken out two
Goliath's they're countered they took
out energy and g2 on their way here then
being the muffin man and now they're
looking out to take another one this
would be quite the tournament run if
they were able to pull it off the
problem was that gale-force weren't just
any opponent they were via moment a
powerhouse who would go on to join
Dignitas after solidifying themselves as
gods of the game but the muffin men
didn't care but can they hold the line
versus the high-powered offense of
[Applause]
he feeds off of the feeling just one
goal of just one championship here we go
Game seven between the muppet min and
Gil force the muffin man were both able
to bring the series to a full seven
games and edge it out following an
absolutely nail lighting in the quarter
can they keep it up it's going into
careful's territory Oh fill up in the
air there is still a chance the muffin
men aren't trying to knock it down is it
going to be knocked out no it's still up
in the air keeping it going is kill for
ladies and gentlemen dreamin can Lana
make some noise for your champions the
muffin man following the unlikeliest of
cinderella stories this humble hungry
content reader had finally managed to
make his mark on the world stage
the winning team here the muffin men
somebody picked these people up please
they were some of the best team we've
ever seen needless to say someone did
after striking gold in Atlanta
squishy had proven that he was the real
deal it came as no surprise then when
his team got signed by a Tier one legacy
org cloud nine everything was moving so
fast it was like we had such a good team
we lost the qualifiers
maybe we used our sub whoo and it was
good gimmick was my friend for for so
long before I even like I'm gonna touch
with GT or anything like that series R
sub I do he was good but I didn't take
it to be that good with it and like we
went from doing so good to so bad so
good I'm in cloud nine it was such a
roller coaster of emotions and I'd know
what to feel but I was just like rolling
with it I guess I was giving every
single tournament mile and I was just I
don't know try to make everyone like see
that cloud I didn't make a mistake as a
way of brandishing their newly acquired
banner c9 took season four of the our
LCS by storm after taking first in the
North American play in they sauntered
their way to a 6-1 finish over the
course of the regular season
what a way for North American league
play to end as we see cloud knight
crowning sitting right up cleanly at the
top of the standings the problem was
that their rivals g2 had managed that
very same finish xi9 had established
themselves as the strongest roster in
the region but only by an extremely
narrow margin there was a tremendous
amount of hype surrounding the squishy
squad going into the finals North
America hadn't taken in our LCS title
since season one and c---nine sudden
dominance was being heralded as a return
to form for the region at large but I
think for the European team
that are waiting backstage they have to
worry about the scene time we saw in
Game two a plus the scene that we saw in
Game five but as soon as c9s first match
against PSG LGD rolled around it became
abundantly clear no amount of hope
praise or fanfare was gonna win them a
world championship
it's not able to get behind that but
it's teammate trusting him and did the
follow-up Corbett stay right behind in
net with four do-or-die series standing
in between them and the grand finals
there was no question if c9 were going
to win this tournament they'd need to go
on one hell of a run and man did they
[Applause]
just on the wall and that will do it
left mere could possibly carry there's
no way he's got enough boost to get it
all the way down the field right now and
torment will put it into the ground
cloud9 are the North American regional
champions before long
they found themselves in a face-off
against Akron ovie led g2
this is an incredibly important match
potentially imagine these guys careers
in a certain sense it's cloud 9 vs G to
North America vs. North America to see
who dances on to the top three of the
World Championships c9 lost the first
game but managed to take the next two in
succession then just as squishy was on
the cusp of advancing his rivals
prevailed forcing a fifth and final game
finally touch g2 keeps their hopes alive
it moves into Game five in the last 30
seconds of that game
finally able to break that GG defense
but they incredible seeing them from
Kenobi in reserve to keep that one goal
lead was so huge but in a game five in
which only one goal would get passed
either team squishy
came through
what do you think that 5050 recommend
against boats [ __ ] and torment and his
football movie closed room and obstacle
for that far back after winning three
series in succession c9 squared up
against method in Game one of the lower
bracket finals and that's where it
happened
the player to invent the shot
and
squishy performed the most miraculous
maneuver in rocket leagues brief yet
illustrious history his signature
ceiling shot it wasn't just the fact
that squishy had managed to pull a
ceiling shot off on the world stage it
was the way he did it or better yet the
way he didn't and just just watch admire
practice it at home and fail because you
can't do this I can I'm sorry you
probably can't it's hot enough to good
Lamba to fake it under the inhale Laney
flipster Hey he struck fear into the
hearts of method with that shot flipping
his car faking the hit and then shooting
it and using his flip at the final
second we talked about squishing all the
time being a pioneer of those sealing
shots and competitive and he pulls it
off in the lower final and he didn't
even smile by rotating his car forward
squishy was able to trick both defenders
into thinking that he'd already made
contact with the ball he hadn't of
course and the defenders were baited
into jumping too early as a result it
was pure unadulterated artistry
unfortunately it wasn't enough it's been
a great one for cloud nine but method
has shown their mettle and they will pay
endurance method losing the first two
and then winning four in a row c9 simply
weren't strong enough to stand up to
their european opponents but there was
no mistaking it that goal would live on
for as long as there was rocket League
to play despite emerging from our LCS
season four as one of the best teams in
the world season five saw c9 falter in a
way that few predicted a line we've ever
performed to their fullest on line and
when we get on land is when we really
come alive and we were your best and you
can see that with like our results like
online compared to Lane is completely
different things and I think that I
don't know like that season yes we
didn't play as well in line but I'll and
we still finished through like that's
what matters is making Alana's amost
important thing with regional
competition getting stronger
Squishy's roster only managed to take
third in the regular season and they
barely qualified for the finals people
always say anything weaker than EU but
there are so many teams in it here who
can threaten the top of na like I mean
like any of the lower two teams and na
people wouldn't agree with this but any
in the lower teens na are more than
capable of beating energy due to us for
sure
easily they can if there is play well
season five soft squishy achieve his
most mediocre our LCS result of his
career it also saw his European nemesis
Dignitas become back-to-back world
champions and arguably the greatest
rocket league roster of all time suffice
it to say season 5 didn't quite go as
squishy had planned season six well that
was a different story coming out of
season five it was clear c9 still had a
ways to go if they were gonna close the
gap between them and the European
monolith that was Dignitas by the time
the season six finals rolled around they
weren't even considered the best team in
North America they were however a fan
favorite people loved squishy
both as a competitor and as a content
creator
he'd cemented himself as one of the
game's true mechanical gods still
everybody wanted nothing
more than to see squishy live out his
dreams people had had the opportunity of
seeing squishy go from a gifted youtuber
to a top-tier professional and they
wanted his story to have a happy ending
the issue is that c9 lost their very
first upper bracket matchup against we
dem girlz
which meant that they'd have to start
their run in the first round of the
lower bracket
remember that run from season four that
one was for best of five series and c9
were only able to win three of them this
one would be for best of fives and three
best of sevens since they'd also need to
reset the bracket come the grand final
so with high hopes and low expectations
the community watched as cloud 9
embarked on what might be the single
greatest lower bracket run in the
history of eSports I'm fully expecting
cloud nine to make an incredible lower
bracket run these guys are just too good
only a one goal game banking one and
again there's tour man and he's out of
this second do not want to see them put
on match point
but not if squishy and gimmick have
something to say so we know squishy for
his scoring he does not have a goal in
this series it's five assists and now he
finally adds one this is exactly what we
were expecting cloud nine we saw how
close it was between Wii and Wii damn
girl R then we dem girls and now going
up against a two minds cloud nine just
had such a big advantage and they
continue to just Excel we now have cloud
nine versus energy the two best teams
from North America it was cloud nine all
season long up until the regional
championships with NRG pink keys to
success for cloud nine or how well they
get the ball away from the side squishy
down the middle
squishy gets to when that torment can't
capitalize just does not go holes it but
Garrett G can't get there torment will
put it in for the past play instead
three players both America versus Europe
cloud nine falling to the lower bracket
early on in this tournament but a three
over two in minds three two over energy
to get to this point
going up against flipside tactics a fan
favorite mystic next to his own box cut
off by squishy up immediately as torment
not a great touch to get pushy in
midfield ten seconds for flipside they
gotta go the distance
[Applause]
spread out flipside
9 gonna put this game away they have
their eyes on the grand finals standing
in their way of the Chiefs spirit if I'm
saying it right here these guys are the
true challengers to take down Dignitas I
expect them to make a historic run no
one has ever made top 4 by going down to
lower round 1 except for this cloud 9
squad they are taking out everybody and
they only have two more teams in their
way
squishy on the transition Tommy now try
to play it out towards the middle of the
field just try to harass squishy squishy
he's gonna be pleats everybody is best
in North America one of the best in
Europe and you don't know what's gonna
happen there's a lot on the line for
these guys in cloud 9 they've been on a
heck of a tear for the lower bracket
yeah I mean it's it's it's two
completely different situations cloud 9
they lost to wean em girls early but
they almost had that series since that
point cloud 9 has just been on an
absolute tear where as we dem girls
suffered a pretty devastating defeat at
the hands of Dignitas pushing through
spandau back down beating everybody off
the backboard gimmicks they're all by
himself
tapping down
[Applause]
you heard them on the desk talking about
a the final five Remco can't do it that
clear we'll do it cloud9
secure their chance to challenge
Dignitas in the finals it'll be north
america versus europe for the world
championship
if squishy was to earn his first World
Championship he'd need to dethrone the
dynastic Dignitas no easy feat of course
since they'd won the last two finals in
succession Dignitas were everything but
squishy and his brethren weren't
structured patient and disciplined a
well oiled European car bawling machine
c9 on the other hand were rowdy loose
and loved to improvise but they could
afford to be since squishy could set up
goals from anywhere it's in fact a top
not the greatest touch
swishy with the challenge tournament
again gimmick with a shooting
opportunity good first touch that shot
splishy all the way in the back corner
gets the demo on panda great read from
Keita
I'm running out Dignitas on the cusp of
being shut out and I miss their gimmick
it's gonna clean that above a cloud nine
secure this game it's going on with this
Dignitas came to mind a loan when the
season is cloud nine were dunking on
Dignitas and after resetting the bracket
they had no intention of letting up
squishy has a chance going for the
double tap and squishy extends the lead
torment you hear the chance and an MVP
caliber finish right there
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
rocket League
[Applause]
the title
to North America carpet what series
and they do it cloud9
your season six world two beards
[Applause]
it's pretty hard to stumble upon a
player as adored as squishy and it isn't
because he's a world champion a talk to
your striker or mechanical god it's
because people got to witness every step
of his journey this is episode number 9
over 2 grand share to watch as he
experimented innovative look dr. squishy
c'est magnifique Sal ultra dollar boot
salad I saw and improved to see him
embark on the path to greatness make it
to the end
cloud9 your season and thank everyone
who decided to go along for the ride
the best part though the rides not over
I'm so proud of my teammates and how
they performed I don't think it's
necessarily a playstyle you should copy
but we played great and I'm so proud of
them thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and bring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Applause]
you